Most psychologists agree.
The best way to have somebody increase
empathy is to engage in something called
perspective taking.
Imagining that you're someone else
trying to cognitively and emotionally
understand some event from their
perspective.
It's hard to do that.
Often.
We don't have the facts,
meaning I don't know what's going on
through your mind.
I don't have an experience of what it's
like to be you and it's also very
effortful.
It's hard to actually imagine what it's
like to be someone else and in fact,
when it comes to empathy,
we're often thinking about unpleasant
things.
For example,
what it's like to be homeless and the
brain doesn't want to go there.
So vr is a really neat tool because it
takes that cognitive effort out.
It makes increases accuracy so you're
not operating on stereotypes.
You may have in your mind what you can
actually experience the life of someone
else as as that person lives.
Since 2003 I've been running experiments
that take a person,
puts her in virtual reality and gives
her an experience that you couldn't have
in the real world.
This could be being in a different place
or could actually be becoming a
different person.
So the first study we ran was about
ageism and we took college age students
and they walked up to a virtual mirror.
And the reason we have a virtual mirror
is to show the person there they've
become different via a process called
body transfer.
This is a neuroscientific process where
if you move your physical body and you
have an Avatar that moves what's called
synchronously,
that beans at the same time that you
move your arm,
you see it's our move.
And you see that in a mirror as well on
the first person over time.
The part of the brain that contains the
Schema for the self expands and includes
this external representation as part of
the body.
So by using a virtual mirror and showing
somebody moving with a mirror,
you can literally feel like you've
become someone else.
You can be a different gender,
a different age,
uh,
you can become disabled,
you can have a,
a different skin color.
And our first study took college aged
students.
We had them become older,
about 60 to 70 years old.
We then network the second person into
virtual reality.
And there was a conversation between the
two.
Over time,
the conversation turned to stereotypical
concepts about being older.
So perhaps you didn't have a good memory
and the stereotypes were activated in
the conversation.
So while wearing the body of someone
else who's an older person,
I felt discrimination firsthand as a
subject.
And what we showed in that first study
published in 2005 was that subjects who
had gone through this treatment became
less ageist.
Uh,
when they came out.
For example,
if you ask them to list words about the
elderly,
they were less likely to list a words
that were stereotypical.
Since that first study,
we've run dozens of studies.
We've looked at empathy in terms of
becoming a different race,
becoming different gender,
even becoming a different specie.
If you become a cow,
how does that make you think about
animals?
And what our research has shown is vr is
not a magic tool.
It doesn't work every single time.
Uh,
but in general across all of our studies
of Vr tends to outperform control
conditions.
For example,
imagining you're someone else via role
playing or reading about case studies,
this experience of walking a mile in
someone's shoes,
it tends to be more effective at causing
empathy and behavior change towards
others.
At the 2018 tribeca film festival,
we're going to premiere a piece called
thousand cut journey.
I'm working with Courtney cogburn.
She's a professor at Columbia and she
studies implicit bias and black white
racism.
The piece is designed to show how people
of color do not experience racism once
or twice in their lives.
It's,
it's a process they go through pretty
much every day.
And so this piece is you start out as an
elementary school child and you're in a
classroom,
uh,
you then become a teenager,
and you're interacting with police
officers.
You then become an adult who's going on
a job interview and what you experienced
while wearing the body of a black male
is implicit bias that happens repeatedly
and over time.
And so that's a piece that's going to
premiere in April.
And what we're currently doing is
running experiments to test to see if it
changes attitudes and what aspects of
the experience are most effective at
changing those attitudes.